peu à son difficultés de la circulation
une recette
la savate c'est ainsi en effet que la
boxe française longtemps oubliés dans
les pages du dictionnaire revient au
goût du elle possède à paris son
sanctuaire hautement intellectuel ou
d'honorables gentlemen vienne renouer
avec les exercices chère amie laure
l'argent
ce qui nécessite on le comprend une
sérieuse mise en train préalable et
justifie la transformation de la salle
d'armes du club en une sorte d' annexe
de l'opéra
[Musique]
après quoi rien ne vaut une bonne
démonstration pour mettre dans
l'ambiance
la boxe française sport complet qui fait
appel aux jambes comme au bras requiert
souplesse et décision et s'il est aisé
de porter les coups bas
il faut une bonne détente pour porter
des coups au flanc
davantage encore pour les porter dans la
figure
[Musique]
dès lors il va de soi que de la théorie
à la pratique il reste encore un sérieux
pas à franchir les meilleures bonnes
volontés peuvent en être ébranlé
ah ah
[Musique]
toutefois la boxe française que
pratiquer nos valeureuses aïeux n'est
pas un sport de dilettante
[Musique]